don't worry gracie
the curtain only goes up when everyone
has a part to play
oh okay i got you uh oh whoa watch out
for those audio cables
i'm gonna be sick
i am not going out there without gracie
neither am i
um a little help no pressure
oh cool so the actors in that animated
short film you just saw that's a segment
of it
they are actually local theater students
alex yeah it looks so cute
so the students couldn't perform of
course during the pandemic so
instead they became animated and hector
mejia is live from thurman white academy
in henderson
with the details hector good morning
this is such a cool story
it's so cool it's also heartwarming and
let me tell you why it's cool number one
it features 22 local students number two
it's going national
number three these local stars have
already been interviewed by
national networks and this morning
they're joining us live we have
ava and everett to talk to us about
their role here
all right so what was it like you guys
were not
on stage doing plays and then you have
this huge opportunity
what was it like well at first it was
really hard because you're not around
the people that
share your passion so when you're
sitting at home in your bedroom it's
hard to think that you were even there
in the first place and you voiced it
from your bedroom
yeah well it was in my living room yeah
but
yeah it was it was a crazy opportunity
that we were given so it was
we're really fortunate to have the
opportunity ever what was it like for
you
um it was it was awesome i loved it
just like to just like to think that cox
would just give us this opportunity
i i can't believe it so tell us what was
it like not being able to play on stage
or do a play on stage and then you know
do a voice
like this and being featured in a short
animated film
um well fun i i can't believe
that that coped has like really
like become like a normal thing in our
lives but
like like just like hybrid school and
like
no and like no theater at all um
so it's really sad and
then cox came to us with this animated
film
and it's definitely better than uh
and it's definitely better than a play
because
it doesn't really have like a red carpet
event you know
but surprise or spoiler alert there will
be a red carpet event right
it already happened yeah we had cox gave
us the amazing opportunity to go and we
got to
we got to see some of the people who
were in the cartoon with us and we got
to
sign people signed signed posters of the
film it was really amazing so we had a
red carpet everyone got all glammed up
we had this backdrop we had paparazzi
and then on may 9th what's happening on
may 9th
it's gonna it's gonna be on it's gonna
air on tv
and not just in vegas right it's going
to air really all over the country
yeah 14 on your cox cable what was that
i said channel 14 on your cox cable all
right lastly before we let everyone go
um you know for you know other kids who
are wanting to be actors just like you
guys a
small bit of advice just briefly um
well i would say just
i if you find this to this doesn't go
just to like
acting people but it to everybody if
you find something that you love and you
want it
then you have to then you have to work
like
really really hard and good things will
happen
like this like i was completely
surprised when this
happened so so just work really really
hard
all right well thank you guys for having
us this early in the morning at sunrise
the sun is shining
you guys are shining so we're gonna sit
here talk a little bit more about this
but for now reporting live
from henderson hector mejia 8 news now
back to you guys oh my gosh
they are the cutest students that's
awesome
i love that and and and hector just two
of
22 students wow and and it wasn't you
know this is an animated movie of course
but they're getting to work with
an academy award-winning director this
wasn't just something they threw
together here this is a proper
movie here so that's what makes it even
cooler
that's true and lastly they look just
like their characters in that short film
take a look they look just like the
characters i was going to get these two
pieces of paper together
ava and everett i love that hector that
is so cool and
they are so well watch it may 9th can't
believe it yes
on channel 14. communications for
helping make that happen hector good
stuff we'll catch up with you
later